con la vita siamo a posto Dobbiamo solo
capire
allora
merda Corri Bastardo Bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovissimo
video di wrestling
Buona visione Eh avanti Ragà Comunque
non ho capito tizio qua che cosa mi
abbia aiutato ma il mio amico poteva
darmi una mano anche sale nel sacco
riceve
Rai il corpo chissà
bene
che
Vabbè dai Pensavo peggio cazzo
si scrive così da quando
le poche parole Io sono Luis Serra si
chiamava
È simpatico Comunque lui
Io sono già visto
Ho capito che vuoi fare
ti trovi spesso in situazioni simili Sì
tutte le domeniche quando vado a giocare
al bingo
Sei qui per cercare qualcuno
fammi indovinare magari una signorina
dispersa
una ragazza
balla la Madonna va bene
di spostare una
signora una signorina
dove
ho visto trascinare qualcuno
verso la chiesa
Sì vabbè ma raga Ma chi è che ci ha
legati qua un rincoglionito
Porca [__]
era lui che c'ha la legate occhio
ma bellissimo No vabbè ragazzi
fantastico ma sto male lì il mio padre
lo so ragazzi sempre così
Grazie non liberarmi a me per carità
ci vediamo amico
simpatico
Luis Serra
avevano fatto un culo quadro per avere
tutta quella roba lì pronto
al nido ho localizzato aquila reale
sembra sia prigioniera in una chiesa
sembra
ve l'ho detto un uomo che ho incontrato
un certo Luis Serra
mi è sembrato troppo presto Puoi fare
dei controlli su di lui
è sembrato sospetto l'unico che ti ha
aiutato
bene così potrò confessare tutti i miei
peccati quando uno ma quali peccati non
ne hai neanche uno tu sei un uomo
d'onore Lion uomo donare non vedo una
sega potreste mettermi che ne so
dici dov'è va bene Ah c'è un coltello
ignorate veloci con R2 metterei pronto
R1 Ah guarda qua Ci sono anche le
tecniche invece riesco a recuperare un
attimino di vita perché faccio schifo
Eh beh solo col coltello raga Minchia ma
non me la ricorda sicuramente sono parti
nuove queste io me le ricordavo proprio
riesco a recuperare intanto qualcosa
ma in tutto questo lo zio Dov'è andato
piano piano fai piano piano
Secondo me ragazzi devo andare Stealth
qua Sì lo so L'ho già fatto 26 volte
Altro che mamma
Minchia raga furtivo qua un casino eh
coltello da cucina
sei anche riparato il coltello e tutto
questo come è possibile era rotto prima
lo vedo lì che è bello A posto Va bene
è come cazzo ci arrivo fin lì eh devo
per forza allora sparare con gli
attacchi con L1 va bene
Hello
Beh parato benissimo Bravo complimenti
Minchia Beh a Forte il coltello a parare
un po' meno però forte in generale
una cosa doveva fare non è servita
niente Me la devo cavare ancora col
coltellino in tutto ciò scusi
Non ti girare Non ti girare Non ti
girare come non detto Arrivederci
non è che devo schiacciare le uno nel
momento preciso forse non ho capito bene
come si fa però vabbè Nel dubbio intanto
chi se ne frega le armi le abbiamo
appena riprese credo di qua
No non sono quelle armi dove cazzo devo
andare per riprendermi le mie armi
Eccole okay
a tempo pure Va bene vai vai vai corri
minchia
Guarda quanta roba che c'ho Madonna
fammi un miliardo di munizioni per la
pistola ma proprio un miliardo e mezzo
che proprio non devo averne devo aver
non dà più spazio per nient'altro ok
Madonna quanta roba ho preso c'ho molta
più roba di prima bene Abbiamo imparato
a usare il coltello non che mi servisse
ma vabbè
cioè tranne a parare quello non l'ho
capito
da questa parte straniera ma il badi No
in italiano non sono abituato per niente
mi fa stranissimo no Raga lo voglio in
inglese lui minchia
No Voglio sentire il lupo vedo l'ora di
fare i compiti genere ti prego Benvenuto
benvenuto
a fare quel mercante puoi comprare armi
oggetti al mercante una volta completato
un incarico per reclamare la tua
ricompensa parlando col mercato
[Musica]
Minchia raga è stranissimo sentirlo
parlare così allora la doppietta la
posso comprare da lui Ah mi dà pure i
soldi va bene collane di perle sporca la
prima Viola caraffa mi dà un bordello di
soldi anche Rubino però il resto lo
vendo
ho un sacco di soldi io questa la
comprerei perché anche l'estensione
della valigetta mi serve tantissimo eh
fucile a
pompare e poi una bella Scarica per
farli volare via grazie lo sapevo già
però va bene lo fa a posso aumentarmi la
potenza delle Armi però Eccole qua non
ho così tanti soldi raga ancora allora
Vendi anche questo e si volendo adesso
posso potenziarmi la pistola Vediamo se
me la fa fare Yes
pistola potenziata non è male Ragazzi
allora munizioni carabina sono dragonfly
sono nuove queste Però non ho la
carabina me ne fotto ma ho il fucile a
pompa e ho anche un sacco di proiettili
che avevo presi prima li avevo tutti la
parte e ho anche aumentato la Madonna
quanto picchia occupa un fucile a pompa
vediamo un po' troppo però va bene eh
proiettili sono là allora qua serve uno
stemma a forma di aquila che non abbiamo
Oh my god abbiamo trovato il Mercante
raga stranissimo ma fighissimo
quanti cazzo siete
credo che sia molto più potente adesso
la mia pistola o sbaglio
pesetas No no mi servono i preset
ragazzi adesso pesetas sono la prima
cosa da trovare eh vediamo se riesco a
salire dove mi porta qua
ma siamo ancora al lago in tutto che
cazzo siam finiti raga dov'è che c'è un
portati
boh Vabbè comunque siamo non so dove c'è
Madonna che casino
Ma che è sto posto là c'è un quello se
lo faccio saltare fa un casino Eh mo
come scendo sicura arriva la Madonna
No vabbè
Ok
va bene
Dai minchia Una porta c'era già chiusa
dove vai tu
uno
e mi fa morire che ragazzi Quanti sono
Fermi Fermi Fermi Fermi Fermi Fermi
Fermi Fermi
Vabbè
spray medico Giusto per non morire Ok
bene arrivederci vediamo se riesco a
farli passare tutti da qua sarebbe utile
visto che c'è quel tizio pure con le
bombe
Ma se l'è tirata addosso da solo eh
Arrivederci
è morto solo uno veramente
hai tentato di schivare Ma non sei
riuscito bene così
va bene minchia
Ma ragazzi ma tutto a posto Minchia ma
state calmi Ma che cazzo è Oh Vabbè
scendi vado piano stavolta non vado
pianissimo
tanto vale che lo faccia fuori così
tanto uno ne fa fuori non è che posso
quello là attenzione quello del bomber
ok questa qua la secco
poi è caduta tutta Bellissima sta roba
Bellissima sta dinamica Ok occhio occhio
occhio occhio occhio
benissimo benissimo benissimo
occhio questo qua Perfetto dai se non si
è rotta la scatola è tutto ciò non so
come Ok va bene Stavolta è partita molto
meglio pieno di gente ok Questo c'ha una
roba esplode
Perfetto dai quanta gente c'è sto posto
porca [__] Occhio che qua di nuovo
finisco
che mi fanno Oh bravissimo li ha fatti
fuori lui chi è stato grazie grazie
Non so chi sia stato mi hai fatto un
favore alla Madonna C'è un tizio che
lanciava a Granada non so dove non ho
usato neanche il fucile a pompa una
volta Oh ma qua oh
Ma che cazzo è
Ma chi l'aveva visto sto posto ma da
quando c'era un posto qua dentro
e non posso schivare poi un cazzo Oh
Meno male mi ha salvato il culo la bomba
fuori uno fuori uno una sega Lion e
un'ora che sparo fuori uno un cazzo
fuori uno Ma che fuori uno sono 2000
bene
Oh siamo finiti
basta
possiamo giocare a Resident Evil Non lo
so È un'ora che vado avanti a ammazza
gente c'è una roba imbarazzante minchia
E finché sono finiti veramente Oh porca
[__] 2 ore uniamo queste due e via Ho
anche recuperato un po' di vita è che
non ne ho più lo sapevo anche prima Lion
c'è qualcosa qua che non ho visto ha uno
stemma dell'Aquila anche questa a
emblema l'ho trovato qui adesso posso
tornare indietro perché alla fine era
questo che dovevo trovare qua giusto C'è
veramente Qua c'è rispetto agli altri
c'è un casino atroce
una valigetta piccola chiave ho trovato
Ah questa è per aprire i cassetti mi sa
Eh
minchia e non c'era prima Questo
è uscito Allora dove sei uscito non
c'eri prima
Vabbè Vabbè
Ragazzi allora l'abbiamo fatta tutta sta
parte sono stato bravissimo Cioè a parte
prima che sono morto Vabbè vediamo se
riesco ad andare Ah c'è ancora uno zio
[Musica]
Ah ma c'è una cosa là l'avevo visto
Scusate mi sto aspettando che scendete
io non commento va bene non commentiamo
non commentiamo benissimo Allora risorsa
Ah eccola qua questa se la chiave apre
questo affare Ah no si aprirà senza bene
Rubino Va bene Allora ragazzi Abbiamo
tutto possiamo tornare indietro
teoricamente da qua
ok
non esce niente da quella roba lì che è
strano
Ma chi è Ma c'è gente ma basta quanti
cazzo siete Ma quanta gente c'è in sto
gioco Incredibile ho mai visto una roba
così oh Mo me ne vado
me ne fotto proprio posso andare qua
sopra
Ah qua sei oh
minchia
scusi che c'è gente che devo fare io
faccio quello che possa non è che posso
questa molto parlavo di questi qua
ma pessima idea pessima idea pessima
idea ragazzi pessima idea impariamo
sempre alla gente tanto non muore
le piante verdi Non male
Andiamocene ragazzi stato poco utile
Però ho trovato l'emblema di qualcosa è
qualcosa servito sto casino Allora qua
ci ficco il coso nuovo ok l'emblema la
chiave che ho preso ma che Ah pure
dritto devo mettere e dall'altra parte
devi gira Ah ok Vai
Perfetto Va bene mi devono anche fare
già non basta l'ansia pure i neuroni
devo spremere e non ne ho tanti ragazzi
Quindi quello che posso fare lo faccio
Oh almeno ci rivediamo eh fratello è
stato bello
tanto lo ritroviamo Comunque non ho mai
capito come però merda C'è un tizio
Vabbè che i mercanti Comunque in tutti i
Resident Evil li troviamo ovunque senza
un motivo eh
sono qua come come fai a cercarmi se
guardavi di là ero merda
Non l'avevo visto Questo sei goduto lo
spettacolo però grazie gentile Adesso
puoi uccidermi Però forse ti faccio
fuori prima io sono tutti uguali a nonno
Chuck Comunque questo notate
benissimo sono morto via dalle palle
tutto quello che riesce a dire io Non è
questo
e che cazzo c'ha chi t'è muort sono
stato decisamente meglio Comunque
rispetto a come sto conciato adesso
Scusate raga Ci hanno droppano le cose
sti cosi Cioè non è che io sono
animalista però non posso i Pezzetta
questi sono Corvi che c'hanno il conto
in banca io non non lo capisco a me
servirebbe gentilmente gentilmente non
lo so eh Un
Around a me vuoi aspetta eh
No ragazzi Mi serve Sto morendo sto
letteralmente schioppando Ah c'è
un'altra roba di attenzione che qua è
pieno di trappole Madonna ragazzi ma
nelle trappole ci possono cadere anche
gli infetti No perché sarebbe
straordinario
Ok
pianta verde oltre che culo che culo
vediamo di fare una cosa fatta bene
mettiamo queste due Yes calma Baby con
la vita siamo a posto Dobbiamo solo
capire
allora
merda Corri Bastardo corri forti Non è
vero Non ci credo non ci posso credere
Porca [__] No vabbè ragazzi
da dove cazzo siete usciti non c'era
nessuno qua prima ma come cosa cosa cosa
succede io mi sta ancora seguendo lo zio
Mannaggia chi t'è muort Ragazzi
allora allora allora No
ragà pezzi di merda No vabbè ma non lo
posso fare fuori non ce la faccio
ragazzi siamo messi male allora Fermi
Fermi
teste di merda Allora innanzitutto
uno
picchia non so se mi conviene ragazzi ma
non lo faccio fuori cioè mi conviene
andare avanti ce lo supero
cioè Allora faccio il giro lo lascio
vado via
è troppo forte non lo faccio fuori raga
No no non ce la faccio a farlo fuori
cioè giuro vado a corro corri finché non
arrivi in un punto dove non puoi puoi
raggiungerti perché se no sono finito
C'è una bomba qua attenzione e allora
aspetta fermo fermo passa così ok Forse
quello non la vede la bomba attenzione
fermo Vai vai non so se la vedono Non ne
ho idea Porca [__] non l'ha vista
lo si apre chiuso
non ci credo forse no non è questa la
chiave merda
Porca [__] No dai vabbè ragazzi
che palle
vabbè no No
Porca [__] no E muoviti
come ha fatto a mancarmi non lo so non
lo so entra fai qualcosa
dove cazzo sono ma puoi entrare qua
dentro Magari non entra qua e attenzione
aspetta non è
entrato Non puoi entrare ce l'ho fatta
ce lo fa Non so come ma non può entrare
Ah testa di culo
sarà l'invio soprattutto l'invidia di
quello stronzo che non penso Ah ecco Ho
trovato la chiave di fuori Mi sa
attenzione Mamma mia oh ma Ditemi voi se
devo fare sta vita di merda costa gente
che corre Ma che cazzo corri Secondo me
se adesso non so se qua fuori eh però
qua fuori uh
Uh
che cazzo ci fa questa cagando eh Oh
merda
stavi cacando Scusa eh Non avevo visto
che stava al banco
Mori però Madonna E che cazzo è Oh devi
morire è morto
c'era il bagno Scusa eh Non avevo visto
che c'era il bagno L'hai fatta tutta
l'ha fatta tutta non c'è più no perché
qua c'è roba Ragazzi ho visto un sacco
di roba utile Io vorrei provare a farlo
fuori il problema è che ci vogliono
62.000 proiettile non so neanche se ce
la faccio tra l'altro Porca [__]
le piccole chiavi aprono i cassetti raga
questo è sicuro con i cassetti che
trovavo in giro all'inizio però non è
che posso tornare all'inizio manco posso
uscire da sta casa No vabbè ma sti cazzi
Oh allora eh [__] il tipo con la
motosega vediamo di trovare c'è un
salvataggio qua dentro c'è qualcosa di
utile in sta casa piano di sopra
Let's go Baby Eccola perfetto Che culo
manco a chiamarla Aspetta che c'ho La
Piola però la pianta Rossa vediamo se
riesco a fa così queste qua a risorse
Hell attenzione posso fare un sacco di
roba teoricamente capito me le sto
tenendo perché tanto per ora non mi
servono
yes come on ci sono i ciondoli in giro
che non ho trovato non so bene A cosa
servono però dovrebbero personalizzarmi
la valigetta che ancora non è successo
comunque dal vecchio contadino il grano
più pregiato dall'esile Porcaro il
maiale più robusto la povera mendicante
il suo amato bambino il padrone ha
accettato questi toni con soddisfazione
ma a me guarda
ah ah non posso entrare Qua dice pure
una roba speciale e devo eh mica un
enigma questo forse Vabbè vediamo più
avanti scopriremo
comunque allegra la casa Meno male
Almeno questo
pisetta per mille ma il Mercante uh ah
ecco sei così prima Appunto ecco quindi
cosa che era il grano Allora il grano
l'altro era il maiale e il bambino vamos
proprio tutto qua ragazzi Tutto qua
Vabbè Fatemi cantare le poche cose
riesco a fare sfera di cristallo a
questa la ficco nella porta
molto facile queste lingue a meno che
non mi spunti qualcuno dalla porta
[Musica]
Che cazzo parlo eh
È stramuort Mannaggia Questa era quella
del cesso ma [__] va' testa di
merda e poi tra l'altro
Porca [__] corri questi sono pure
difficili da far fuori Siete teste di
culo
e [__] va Minchia mi sono cagato
nelle mutande raga No perché quando fai
fuori un tizio poi non ti ricordi più
che si può ancora alzare no sta cosa è
terribile Uh c'è un cassetto però Rubino
bello però grazie è stato
illuminante
Eppure un enigma attenzione Ah devo
metterlo in modo tale che formi con la
figura lì credo
ecco Ma non potete usare delle
merdosissime chiavi c'avevo una chiave
normale Vi prego Cioè io veramente non
ho più
chiave con stemma Ah ho trovato la
chiave finalmente con questa ci apre
Aspetta che c'è qualcos'altro magari no
Salve
Sì sì Sparagli pure che vedo che puzza
Porca [__] che canzone cazzo sei
Cristiano Ronaldo
lo fa il sim eh Lion non ti conviene
fare incazzare sta gente Secondo me
Bravo Buttami giù dalla finestra così
non lo faccio io no perché lui si butta
sangue accolto dentro
[Musica]
c'è una stragnocca fuori che ha sparato
dal finestrino Vabbè Giusto giusto
giusto
incazzato
tanto mi hai iniettato qualcosa l'ultima
volta sto qua Non ho capito bene cosa
non me lo ricordo eh perché ci avevo
giocato a residenti ma non mi ricordo
più
e se ne va così grazie Oh no veramente
non so come ringraziarti
Meno male che non mi ha sprecato i
proiettili perché io non le avrei
neanche sparare mi sarei buttato dalla
finestra direttamente Grazie comunque eh
capitolo terminato Oh bellissimo Finché
ci sono le super [__] dalle finestre
che sparano A me va bene perché tanto
che cazzo me frega però adesso non ci
lamentiamo Eh va bene così quindi
ragazzi secondo episodio di Resident
Evil non ce la faccio a dirlo normale è
impossibile finisce qua Non mancate con
i video di domani che proseguiamo nella
storia iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un
bel mi piace e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi